let's pick up on our caller from the six
five zero area code who's calling today
from six five zero hey David
this is Tyler calling hey Tyler what's
up my call pleasure hey so um I was just
calling because you know I've been
hearing a lot of conversation about like
the transgender athletes sort of issue
where it's like sort of like amplified a
lot in media recently like and you know
there was like the South Park episode
that just happened where they they got a
lot of flack for that and um I was just
curious to know like what how you
respond to people when they when I ask
you about this issue and I'm sure you've
probably talked about it before but you
know I I haven't had a chance to hear
your thoughts on it and I live value
your your opinion and just curious to
know what you how you respond to that so
here's my thought
the reason that the particularly the
right is focusing on the trans athlete
issue is because it's the only way that
they can try to get people to even be
open to their side on the issue of your
house aasaiya t should treat trans
people right so when you look at all of
these other issues right is it a
detriment to society that someone born
biologically male gets to express what
might be a female gender expression by
getting a license that says female no
it's fine like society's gonna be fine
our trans people who are allowed to use
the bathroom that matches their gender
identity looking to go and you know prey
on children or whatever it's like no
that's not understood the only way they
can make it ahead way is by saying hey
if you're born biologically male you
really shouldn't be in a female
weightlifting class and it's like okay
that's fine we can I wouldn't even
disagree with them it's just not even
it's not the it has nothing to do with
how society should be treating trans
people even issues like middle school
soccer like my sister is in high school
her school only has a co-ed soccer team
and they will play against all-boys
teams they will play against co-ed teams
and it's like okay they're at a
disadvantage when they
play against the boys teams they're
allowed to have you know fewer girls on
the field but like nobody's life is
being altered by this in any significant
way and you can find these edge pieces
of track or weightlifting in the
Olympics or it's just it's not really
the issue and they want to put the focus
on it because it's the only one where
they can really even have any argument
yeah I agree with you and it's really
discouraging when like you know I listen
to like you and you know a whole bunch
of other like podcasters and or if you
want to call it that but um you know
like I listen to Joe Rogan sometimes and
it's really unfortunate to hear how he
harps on on that issue like ad nauseam
like every episode and I I know he's
like has a huge platform and I'm sure
that definitely you know amplifies that
message and I mean it's just it's just
kind of discouraging to hear like that
being talked about out of all the
different things that are going on in
the world and it's like come on like
yeah thank you for you know that that
definitely answers you know what I was
kind of looking for just to kind of hear
that appreciate it and you know I'd love
to go back on Joe's show any time and
would be glad to discuss it with him and
and I think that would be that would be
useful all right thank you so much for
the call I very much appreciate hearing
from you